[Music]
and here we are this is our 13 o'clock
matinee show episode 47 now this week we
actually saw three movies in the theater
like we used to do we didn't have we
didn't have to like fill it out with
Netflix or Schutter movies because there
were actually three that we wanted to
see this week three decent ones you know
we've actually saw it this first one's
like a Sistine Sistine stones in a movie
what was called 47 47 meters down lion
cage cage day we saw the first one the
first one was good yeah so this yeah
this one is kind of like I mean 47
meters down came out in 2017 and it was
a similar kind of thing it was the same
kind of thing was like these two girls
and they're like trapped underwater 47
meters down there were sharks in it but
it wasn't like shark centric as much as
this one is but this one is pretty much
all about the sharks but there's also
like kind of like a claustrophobia
yeah type of aspect and things of that
nature they're kind of like adventure
survival movies with some horror in them
yes Harrison [ __ ] the first time the
girls were in a damn shark cage and it
break it broke loose the tethered and
went down to the bottom and then one
thing after another happened you know of
course there's always the running out of
air factor yeah and there was a [ __ ]
sharks yeah yeah shark sharks sharks is
a recipe for a good movie if you ask me
I like shark pretty much that's why
there's so many guys terrified of sharks
so anything yet anything with sharks is
jargons alright doesn't take much to
scare alligators didn't work last time
too much of that last movie they had
alligators in it Oh crawl yeah yeah I
didn't really care for that one but this
one was pretty good the twist on this
one is that this girl who she goes out
on this kind of like expedition with a
bunch of these other girls her dad as a
archaeologist and he was investigating
this under underwater city in a cave out
in a cenote near the Yucatan so it's an
old Mayan or Aztec city yeah that's been
flooded flooded and the only way to get
to it
well one of the one of the ways to get
to it is going down into a cenote
doesn't there's no that's the way in but
there's a really way out yeah there is a
way
you can walk there are there's like
different but I mean the whole city
because it you know it's really old and
it's been flooded and some of its
collapsed and stuff so it's like this
little maze and it hasn't really been
mapped or explored or anything because
the dad the dad is he's going down there
so the archeologist archaeologist can
map it but there's another way out there
yeah it leads out to the sea it's just
that's a lot longer anyway they go down
there kind of like on a dare when
they're not supposed to one thing
happens there's a cave-in there's a damn
shark and of course you know they
they're all [ __ ] up and now they can't
come out the way they came in they've
got to go out to the ocean and you know
real tight fits bunch of different types
of sharks blind sharks there's later on
there's sharks that can see it's it's
this is a fun movie it's a fun summer
movie a bunch of cute girls in it
they're all in wet suits or bikinis
using those ass in your face or
something so there's a little bit of
something for everyone you know it's
almost all female cast pretty much I
mean there are a couple of dudes in it
but they don't have a lot of scenes and
yeah they're usually just there to get
eaten by sharks because that's what you
want to see you want to see a lot of
people in by sharks and you do cysteine
so long is not really the star she's one
of the she's one of the supporting cast
she's like the [ __ ] what they call them
you know though yeah she's the [ __ ]
that kind of gets everything from her
character's name is Nicole and like the
whole time I watched the movie going
thanks Nicole yeah she looks great
that's great I did a good job in the
movie you're gonna see more of her in
the movies I'm sure yeah um the the main
characters this girl who's kind of like
a girl next door type and you know the
other girls are making fun of her
because you know she's a I'm dealing not
pretty enough or not smart enough or
just all the above she's too smart cuz I
think one of the other girls calls her
professor yeah they keep bashing on her
what you know I had a few did yeah she
has a good hero's journey type art
through the movie though and it ends up
you know she's all fight sharks and [ __ ]
it's pretty cool yeah and there's some
you know there's a little bit of family
thing in there too with like her her and
her stepsister and they don't really get
along and right you know so there's that
whole thing and like sure ending up with
these three [ __ ] girls and they
they're all kind of having to save each
other now I'm not gonna say like I said
the the first 47 meters down was like a
really good tension filled filled movie
it was largely one location because it
was mostly these two girls and they were
trapped you know under the shark cage
like when his leg was trapped or
whatever and you were mostly worried
about there were sharks but you were
mostly worried about like their air
running out was kind of their more you
know immediate concern whereas this one
there's a lot more moving around pretty
much the whole thing is underwater
there's a couple scenes where they do
come up to the surface like for brief
periods but almost all of this movie is
underwater so in that sense it's very
dark yeah um you know a lot of times you
can't really see what's going on but in
a way I think that works to its
advantage because you're kind of in the
same boat as the protagonist because
they're down there's like all this silt
because there was like a collapse and
they can't really see and then there's
all these sharks in there you don't know
how many there are and they can't see
because you know they've evolved
apparently down in these caves so you
know they're blind and so a lot of it
comes from one these tight spaces
running out of air let you know trying
to find another way out because their
[ __ ] collapsed and you know just trying
to avoid these super predators and then
there's like other [ __ ] too like
horrible currents and all this other
kind of stuff you know I'm nice like
this is I'm gonna say this right this is
a dumb movie it's dumb there's like a
lot of dumb stuff that you're like just
what like how can they hear each other
talking because the masks doesn't cover
their ears they you know they don't show
anything like that but it's like if this
is like you said it's a summer movie
yeah and it's something that you just
kind of like have to watch and it's fun
I like actually had a blast watching
this I'm gonna say I think that like say
crawl the alligator movie I think
objectively that was a better movie but
I had a lot more fun watching this one
yeah you know to me there's a lot of
little not a lot of cool little gimmicks
you know like of course that they're not
only underwater with sharks they're also
in a cave at the same time so you get a
little bit of a descent vibe this is not
nearly as good as that movie but you
know you get a little bit of that it
looks like something Mady Indiana Jones
is a bunch of the United Mayan looking
temples
you know of course the the tunnels get
smaller and smaller and it's too thin
you know you can't fit with your tanks
they're trying to sometimes breathe air
bubbles that have collected up on the
ceiling you know old yeah and they'll
find a little air pockets here and there
it's just pretty cool pretty cool little
movie I mean it's not anything I
wouldn't say it was you know this isn't
one I don't think that's gonna be like a
remember doesn't being a classic or
anything but it's just you know if you
want to go see a movie during the summer
you want to see some cute girls fighting
and underwater [ __ ] and you know people
getting eaten by sharks and getting
stuck in underwater tunnels and stuff
like that and like I said it's it's dumb
but it knows it's dumb you know what I
mean it's not trying to take itself
seriously it knows that people are
watching it to see people get eaten by
sharks so you do get to see that happen
it's only pg-13 so it's not that it's
not really it's not super gory and I
noticed a couple times and I didn't I
don't think I mentioned this to you but
I noticed a couple times that you can
see like the characters mouths moving
you could tell they swore but then they
patched it over with likes to them
saying crap instead of folk or something
like that so I I noted that they were
trying I guess that they did that so
they could like put a little bit more
göran cuz there is there is some gore in
it but it's not like super over-the-top
or anything I think they do have some
masks you can talk in it looks like the
mouth wasn't dinner you know didn't have
a breather in the mouth their mouth is
almost gonna like yeah a suit thing
there might have been an intercom in
there yeah they don't really go into
that yeah it doesn't really matter I
mean you have to be able to hear them
talking to each other obviously
otherwise it's just gonna be like girls
asses like switch me you know if you're
into that that's fine
because it was like an electronic
intercom member because when people's
signals were going in and out as caves
are collapsing yeah so it yeah it was
probably saying yes maybe some kind of
wireless typing yeah they had they had a
technological excuse reason yeah like I
said they just didn't mention I don't
know but like you know what it's just
like I said it's just the kind of movie
it's just kind of dumb and fun and I
have to say I liked the ending of this
yetter than the ending of the original
one yeah cuz like I said it's like a
punch line yeah and I just thought what
when I saw them and it was like that the
whole thing happens at the boat and
everything and I was just like oh [ __ ]
goes on the top but it is it goes over
the top but they build up to that so you
know that that's coming and it does
tonally kind of mass good yeah you just
can't take it serious and it doesn't
take itself too seriously I mean there's
a screaming fish in this for Christ's
sake yes so you can tell that it's
obviously not taking itself seriously so
you know if you like shark movies I
don't see why you wouldn't like this one
it's it's just a big dumb fun shark
movie people get eaten
you know tragedy happens it's wasn't
quite as zany as that other one that we
saw the Chinese shark movie of the mag
the mag it wasn't that crazy
it was insane E is that you could tell
that that the success of the mag that
they they were taken that an account
that they were trying to do it was
totally kind of similar wasn't quite as
funny right but you could tell that it
wasn't like I want to be overly say
there's life the mag you'd probably like
this one yeah I feel like that's
probably a good comparison
okay the second movie we took in at the
theater this week was blinded by the
light yeah which is uh it was actually
directed by Gurinder Chadha who is
probably she's done like a lot of TV and
other movies too but um it's probably
best known for Bend It Like Beckham from
2002 which I think was Keira Knightley's
first movie which actually I really
liked I think I saw it back in the back
when it came out in the theater I see
this movie is very much like that except
with music instead of soccer you know
what I mean so it's it's a coming-of-age
story obviously it's about someone like
finding their voice yeah through music
and what I feel like even if you don't
like Bruce Springsteen like even if
you're not like a huge Springsteen fan
which I'm not like I like some of the
songs and relate to it but it's it's a
very relatable story like I think it's
kind of a universe yes kids Pakistan
he's grown up and what what town was
that it was Luton which is that which is
a suburb of London yeah and you know
he's got a pretty strict dad his dad's
come to the country and trying to work
hard and you know do well for his family
and his dad's basically telling the
whole family not to integrate in with
British culture yeah so this was an 87
back of the day so when we were in high
school yeah so a lot of it you know the
time period I could really relate to
yeah I could as well so he's just kind
of a nerdy Pakistani guy and he runs
into this other guys at the school with
him who was a was a Sikh it was a seka
and he wore a leather jacket and his
turban and [ __ ] and look and he started
talking about the boss and he's like
who's the boss the boss that's what it
turns out he's this Bruce Springsteen
fan so he loans up a couple he's Bruce
Springsteen tapes and he goes back home
I guess he forgets about him for a while
his dad keeps [ __ ] with him trying to
tell him make him do stuff you didn't
want to do and the family's pretty
wrapped up and like laundry service and
he Luton dad loses his job at the
factory yeah cuz it was during you know
yeah eighties in Britain when there were
all those like factory layoffs and some
yeah and then it happened here after
just yeah just right after that you know
they're basically outsourced and
everything to China so his family gets
in this bad economic crunch and there
can handle you know do more and more
work and but then they don't they won't
let him leave to go out and do what he
wants he wants to be a writer
so he gets desperate he listens to those
the Springsteen tapes and it starts
speaking to him you know it's kind of
cool goes in these transitional moments
where it's almost kind of like a music
video and it's showing the lyrics and
because of how the stories kind of
unfolded the lyrics make a lot of sense
to this character yeah so he just starts
basically becoming like part of the cult
of Bruce Springsteen yeah his dad
doesn't want him listening these things
dad thinks Bruce Springsteen's Jewish
took a while to for him to understand
that Bruce Springsteen was not just it
was a funny movie and then finally he
gets to he was starts winning writing
competitions he kind of gets his
independence from his dad and then he
ends up going to the United States and
he's going through customs him and him
and his boy you know he's used to Bruce
Springsteen fans yeah they're asking
what are you coming to United States for
you know this is worked uni goes well
I'm coming for this big writing
competition but that's not why I'm
really here I'm really here to go to go
to the birthplace of Bruce Braley to get
a spark yeah Asbury Park Bruce in New
Jersey you know and the dudes it's all
you're gonna go to home of the boss yeah
you know he's like I can't make him a
better reason company so he ends up
getting a British girlfriend who you
know kind of like his family doesn't
really approve of her he actually gave
her found out about her did they um at
the end because she came to the house
and told him about the writing
competition also her parents don't
approve of him yeah really so they're
like there's a lot of like I said this
is set in 1987 it's set in Britain it's
set during you know within the Pakistani
community in Britain so there's a lot of
like realistic [ __ ] going on in the
background and [ __ ] that happened back
then I didn't go to the UK until
probably seven eight years after that
but you know I I heard from people
growing up over there that's you know
it's pretty true to life
so but the
cool thing about it is that even though
this is not like this is one person's
particular experience you know he's of
Pakistanis growing up in a very
traditional esteem Lee who want him to
do something and he doesn't want to do
it and he feels trapped it's pretty
massive and it yeah and in like this
really oppressive atmosphere he's
actually kind of they're kind of the
kind of gotten kind of boxed in where he
has to be a nerd yeah and all of his
little sisters are kind of nerdy but
then you find out later that his sisters
all have secret they're all doing
secrets because I mean you know because
and I think that like I said even though
this is one characters because this is
based kind of loosely based on a real
guy it's based on his memoirs
his name is sarfraz Mansoor and so he
based this someone on his experience
growing up and he's like in real life is
like a huge Bruce Springsteen fan it
says at the end he's seen him like 150
times that it showed like all these
pictures of him with Bruce Springsteen
like four users were like oh my god
here's this guy again but um so it's
kind of loosely based on his experiences
but the cool thing about it like I said
I think really the the message of the
movie is that even though this is this
one kids experience and it's you know a
very different experience maybe than
like what I had or what other people had
growing up but it's something that
everybody can relate to it's still
pretty universal it's a universal Amy
even if it's not Bruce Springsteen even
if it's not like even I'm really in a
Muslim family yeah like yeah because
everybody kid that's growing up can
relate to you feeling like you don't
belong or affiliate parents don't
understand you or feeling like they like
other people's expectations of you are
kind of like oppressing you in some way
he had the dude the dude that lived
across the street from him was a British
guy who stood up for music his best
friend yeah they had grown up together
yeah they grew up together he was big in
his life in new ways yeah he was a new
wave got Matt and he had girlfriends and
was partying was in his own band and
blah blah blah and he was making the
same complaints as as as the Pakistani
guy yeah Pakistani guy really wasn't
buying it though he's like dude you're
living the life yeah it's like you got
girlfriends and you can you know but but
I think like I said in part and one of
the things I liked about it too because
I think really the heart of this I mean
I think it has a lot of heart to it but
I think the heart
is the relationship between Javed you
know the main character and his dad
because they could very easily have made
his dad seem like a villain yeah but
even though he seemed sopra and you like
relate to the kid he's you know he's 16
in the movie and it's like you can
relate to like you know you don't know
anything and it's like we are your
parents and you're trying to he's trying
to push him in this direction that he
doesn't want to go in but they humanized
the dad I mean the dad you can
understand where the dad is coming from
too because I mean when the dad was a
kid he you know against the wishes of
his dad he left Pakistan because he went
to UK and he want to make a better life
and you can see when the dad gets laid
off you know you can see there's like a
couple of scenes where they just show
his like vulnerability because it feels
like he's responsible for his whole
family and he's failing them yeah and
he's useless so you can see why he
pushes his kids so hard because he
doesn't want his kids to end up the way
he ended up like work in a factory and
then go there was a different angle
there too
his dad is telling him to succeed the
way he succeeded but he ended up failing
yeah so what he was telling the son to
do was not applicable what's not which
it was just the same [ __ ] that me and
Jenny went through in our generation
yeah which is what I guess that I will
relate to that what our schools and what
our parents were telling us to do back
in the 80s
didn't work yeah it was really working
that well for them and then by the time
we were out in the 90s doing our [ __ ]
that world was long gone yeah you know
so really things were changing so
quickly it didn't matter what they told
you cuz nobody knew what the future was
gonna be like yeah I would have no idea
whether we had no inkling of Internet
yeah of YouTube patrons patreon you know
that was just science fiction you know
yeah I don't I don't really think most
people would concede it yeah so they
were trying to train us for jobs that
were quickly disappearing yeah
and there is a little bit of that in the
background there's no like I said you
can't fault the dad because it's like
that's how he grew up and that's how you
succeeded in the world so you could see
why he was watching his kids so he
wasn't a villain he wasn't a bad guy
he just didn't want him to be a taxi
driver yeah he just can't understand he
didn't understand how the real job the
real
jobs that his dad wanted him to do
vanishing yeah he was going out there
trying to find them and they weren't
there well in ever going through that
yeah looking for [ __ ] that your dad
would tell you to do it man that's gone
well it was just like back in the old
days you know and maybe still now I
don't think it's as prevalent nowadays
but I mean when I was growing up I
didn't get it so much for my family
because my family rule they were pretty
cool but um you know people would be
like oh you can't make a living as a
writer you can't make Olivia it's an art
yes it's hard right but it's hard to
make a living at anything and really I
think nowadays it's much easier to do
that kind of stuff but you can see how
in the 80s you know the kid he wanted to
be a writer and he wanted to like be
important to make a difference it's
tough which a lot of kids do when
they're teenagers and but the dad didn't
really understand that it's like why
don't you you know be a lawyer once you
be an accountant once you know which you
know my granddad told me that kind of
[ __ ] too because he didn't think you
could make any money with design or
writing or anything like that they're
talking about yeah they didn't really
know and like I said it is hard to make
money but it's hard to make money at
anything really um you know make money
as a lawyer yeah nothing is yeah yeah
nothing is set in stone so it's like I
think it's better to like encourage you
gets like do what they want to do
because they're more likely to succeed
because they're gonna work harder at
that because they actually want to do it
instead of just having to do it to make
money um but now one thing I was gonna
say about this movie like I said it's a
really it's like a it's an uplifting
movie it's like a happy movie it's kind
of a feel-good and I mean there's like a
bad [ __ ] happens in this movie but it's
a sweet movie yeah and anybody that I
mean particularly like I said I'm not a
Bruce Springsteen huge Bruce Springsteen
fan although like I said that I think
the music that they used in this was
really well placed and I think it you
know came across really well but I had
the same experience as him you know
except more with like you know New Wave
tennis or post-punk type of music but I
so I could remember feeling that and
feeling the way he felt because I grew
up in kind of a shitty town too and you
know the same kind of thing I lied I
liked the movie I thought the movie was
kind of realistic it also kind of
artistic the way they did yeah it seems
a little bit of a musical yeah I was
gonna say straight out there was a
couple couple scenes there were it
almost went off the rails for me almost
independent body would musical into
Bollywood slightly but not to the top
but it's a Pakistani story so I guess
you can come maybe expect to have
some of that kind of you know in fact in
tech culture in there because I think I
think Pakistan does about the same thing
that Bollywood does is they'll throw ya
in every damn movie data and there's
some of that
it says they don't do anything like a
big cuz this is like a lower budget
movie so they don't do any like big
production numbers but there are a
couple of times where I try to sneak it
in there a little bit where it's a yes
like that where he's like just he's
listening to his headphones and he
starts singing out loud and everybody in
the damn crowd ya know it's just gonna
say them like everybody but it's not
it's like a ramshackle way of doing it
which I thought kind of worked I'm glad
that they pulled it back a little bit um
but I enjoyed the movie
I think the trailers were better than
the movie the janitors looked like it
was more intense and action-packed and
more fun in reality it has a lot of that
in it but it's actually a little bit of
a slower story it's a character Drummond
character drama it's also a period piece
it's a good movie just you got to be
expecting it you got to take the movie
on its own terms
yeah I thought was gonna be a
wall-to-wall comedy it's no it's not it
has a lot of funny moments like you know
with the character interactions and
stuff but it's it's not a comedy I don't
think I would call it that it's kind of
like and it's not really a it's not
fantastical um in the same because
there's been like a lot of you know kind
of pop song oriented movies coming out
there you know there was an Arab city
obviously this is a little bit like that
um in the sense that you know he was you
know Freddie Mercury was also an Asian
kid growing up in Britain you know he's
an earlier time period so you got a
little bit of that going on I've seen
this compared to sing Street you know
and things like that but you know we've
also had recent stuff like you know
yesterday and you know movies of that
nature of Rocket Man stuff like that so
this is another one like that but it the
vibe of it is a little bit different
yeah but they're not talking about a
musician it's a guy talking it's a guy
talking about like and his obsession and
and how it's not even so much it like I
said it didn't matter that it was Bruce
Springsteen it just mattered that in his
particular case you know the music of
Bruce Springsteen like spoke to him and
like made him feel like he could find
his own voice and as I'm sure there's
guys in England listening to Bruce
Springsteen when there was people in the
United States kind of listening to
Morrissey and it was the same
thing yeah yeah that's actually a good
in very good analogy to us like yeah
they're basically doing what we were
kind of doing with Morrissey yeah and
it's funny today from a faraway land
yeah and they you know I think he lives
in LA he does well he did for a while he
would move to Italy and then he moved
out I don't know where he's living now
but um but yet it's funny because even
they address it a little bit in the
movie too because you know the the
friend Matt like his friend that he grew
up with who's super into the newbie he's
into like aha and cutting crew and all
that kind of stuff and then so the fact
that he gets like super into Bruce
Springsteen everybody think that's kind
of square because they're like oh that's
like what your dad listens to which it
kind of was because yeah by 87 I mean
foreign in the USA came out in 84 that
was like older people music Bob Seger
and all that kind of stuff yes I
appreciate you know I appreciate it more
now than I did at the time but like at
the tie-in 87 i was like into the Smiths
and Depeche Mode care and stuff like
that so it's like so I could get that to
that later Springsteen seemed like older
people well compared to where we were
coming from this that was really
mainstream I mean it was yeah because
that was every branch on there leather
jackets and I mean particularly in New
Jersey it's like you it you moved in New
Jersey I think you like have to sign a
waiver saying that you love Bruce
birthday another one I think you but
yeah so like I said if you know what
you're getting into like I said it's not
a full-on musical it's not a full-on
comedy it's just kind of it's a
character drama with comedic moments
with a little bit of a fantastical
musical element but I think the cool
thing about it like I said even though
this is a very specific time and place a
very specific person's experience it's
really it's amazing how like universal
that experiences like how you can watch
it and like relate it to your own life
even though that exact thing demands a
high school beginning at college that
period I think it's pretty much about
the same or you know for me I think
that's college I went to army but it was
that same thing yeah it's the same thing
so I think that's what really makes it
work and I'm like I said it really has a
good heart to it and you know
particularly the relationship doing the
son and the dad I think is really well
done and that they didn't really villain
as anyone like you could see where
everyone was coming from even if you
like didn't agree with them you know
what I mean but yeah good flick check it
out
you
all right and the third movie that we
saw in the theater this week was good
boys this one stands out to me this
movie this movie gives me hope for the
future I've seen a lot of reviews that
I'd say it's true you know people that
know us you know we've told many stories
about how we grew up as feral children
basically and it's still going on to
this day this is the kind of [ __ ] that I
have done a lot of this stuff yeah a few
years later this time that we were also
[ __ ] around with a lot of gasoline
yeah set things on fire of a gas when
you steal from a garage yeah and then
guns too you know go get the shotgun you
know you get your dad's arrived
Remington 1100 automatic shotgun and
just start shooting up the woods you
know shooting up all his ammo but that
same thing nowadays Ian's other messing
with drones yeah yeah I mean when I was
a kid I have two brothers in cage I
guess I know that are younger than me
exactly the way it was and yes so pretty
I remember being 12
I remember my brothers being 12 I mean
everything she's blowing stuff up so we
had dart guns we had all kind of crazy
[ __ ] right um so it didn't happen like
you saw in the Goonies that was not the
adventure that you really had when you
were a boy this is a lot closer to the
innovation the actual adventure you
though yeah okay
the thing that I'd loved about this
movie I mean even when I saw the
trailers um I was like 12 year old kids
swearing I'm on board yes there's
something very very funny to me toddlers
getting knocked over and little kids
swearing it's just hilarious to me I
don't know why that is
I swore the [ __ ] storm exactly
because I was like yeah yeah well I
think all kids do I mean unless they're
like really really talking [ __ ] making
[ __ ] up talk about things you don't know
about yeah everything and I think that's
what okay now I've read a lot of reviews
this seems to be getting like fairly
positive reviews like you know like in
the B range for people that give grades
and stuff but um now what pretty much
every review I've seen of this said that
this is like super bad but with 12 year
old kids because super bad was high
school kids
um that should not be surprising because
it's the same producers it's Seth Rogen
and that other guy that he always writes
with they produced this it was actually
written by written and directed by gene
stupnitsky who has done I don't think
he's done like any movies on his own
this is his directorial debut but he's
written some episodes of the office and
things of that nature so this is his
first movie and the conceit of it like I
said super bad with 12 year olds I've
also seen it called a live-action South
Park which it kind of is but I think
this is the only movie that tried to do
is super bad to everything like a
raunchy teen comedy like American Pie or
something like that but with kids this
young now this could go drastically
wrong but I think the reason that this
works so well is because the three kit
first of all the three kids at the
center of it are adorable and amazing
and all of them and the chemistry
between them is just so so good we're
all good kids are all trying Yeah right
thing that's right that's what makes it
work is because all of this horrible you
know there's like there's there's run
around with dildos they're like you know
they get into fights with frat boy is
they like their meat their prey some
unwitting drug mules yeah practicing
practicing practicing on how to kiss on
a damn sex doll which they think is but
that's what I hit one of the kids one of
the kids parents are just like
undercover freakazoids never sex a lot
of the company has a [ __ ] real doll
yeah and it's like you know like a guy
was trying to bite and he goes where is
she from exactly she's quite exotic she
was blogged with dark skin and blue eyes
and you know that this you know big
figure and [ __ ] like that big old
titties and he's trying to he's trying
to buy this sex doll off his kids it's
just [ __ ] hilarious that's right
it just anything that could go wrong on
kind of does go wrong anything any
anything that a kid could [ __ ] up they
do kind of [ __ ] it up any misconception
that a kid could have to have it it's
just hilarious and it is pretty accurate
it's kind of we are
remember us being that's what I mean
that's what that's what I think works
really well especially for people that
can remember what it was like to be that
age or know kids that age is that when
you're 12 years old these kids have just
entered middle school you know they just
entered sixth grade which actually was
still elementary school when I was a
teenager and they're trying to be cool
and they're trying to be mature but
they're not and they don't like hardly
know anything I mean two years later
they'll be like raging hormonal hell
beasts but they're still right well it
was he says he kept trying to rub up on
trees but he was just going through a
tree which is like dirt but the fuzz but
what makes it work like I said is these
kids and like I said the the title good
boys they're trying to be ironic but not
because they are actually good kids
they're innocent they don't know any
better it's like they they say
ridiculous things like you know they
find a tampon and this girl's purse and
say you know yes you know it goes up a
girl's butt to keep babies come from
coming out like that they have like all
these four hilarious misconceptions and
I think the thing that works is that yes
this is a raunchy movie yes it is
putting very young children and these
kids are all that age these aren't like
older kids playing younger these are all
that age and Whittingham pretty [ __ ]
up situations but it works because it's
not I was gonna say it's not
mean-spirited it's not making fun of
them it's just finding humor in the fact
that they're trying so hard to be cool
but they really don't know any better
and one of them there's one of these
kind of like the ladies man he's kind
like the pretty boy his name is Thor
he's like the wild man yeah all right
but everybody's accusing him of being a
[ __ ]
yeah all right he can't have that in the
other ones big old black kid who's kind
of like he's kind of like the cop or the
or the preachers well he's completely
guileless why he just feels guilty about
everything oriented
you gotta be certain ways to do things
yeah that's up if he if he did something
wrong and then these three dudes go on
it's like good yeah I mean they goes
down adventure the whole adventure I
mean it's it's so cute because it's just
like there's so because you can remember
how to get the drone back yeah they were
they [ __ ] up the dick they used the
drone when they weren't supposed to it
was dads
and he needed it for work they lost the
drone they lost the drone to some
teenage girls who took it from him
because they were spying on to find out
how to kiss from it for the kissing
party yeah there was that didn't make
any sense it kind of makes sense they
did did that when the girls told me
didn't make sense well they stole the
girl's purse because the girls took the
took the drums today so he says like
with a beverage but the girls had Molly
yeah the purse is a purse for a party
they were to get high on it that night
yeah I mean so the kids are running
around the kids realize they have these
drugs but they need to get they need the
drugs to get to get the [ __ ] in to get
drunk but they lost the drugs yeah get
more drugs if one thing leads to another
they go to to buy that they sell the sex
doll the sex that I can't I don't want
to so it's just I mean it's so funny
because I mean pretty much the entire
span of the story takes place over one
day or one weekend or something like
that so it's just like these hapless
children like getting into these in
Crete like I said these increasingly
[ __ ] up situations they it's you know
they end up having to buy drugs I'm like
trying to steal beer in front of a cop
there's riot but I mean they end up
going like this frat house and getting
in fights yeah and it's just like that's
right that's right a really good scene
that they had a frat house and it was
like some straight out of a gangster
movie but where there where you're
they're attacking the damn drug the like
the drug pin kingpins there yeah it's
like that but it's you just got to see
it to understand it it sounds worse than
it is in a certain way some of these
kids are thus drugs well they didn't
know they were drugs
yeah they found out that they were drugs
and then they got very very upset yeah
because they took it to a playground and
that was they thought they were to get
into a bunch of trouble they wanted him
to give him over to the cops they told
the cops and the cops didn't believe him
because it was in
flintstones bottle long it's a long
story but it's just yeah it's get rid of
and eventually I forgot how they lost
them
it doesn't matter hid this matter no the
cop did take them yeah that's right I
think he's a Dickens cop did you take
them but yeah II what they were it's
just like I said now I don't know how
like people are gonna take like I said
it's been getting like pretty fairly
positive reviews I think what makes this
work is yes it's really raunchy yes it's
very little children like getting caught
in these [ __ ] up situations and like
swearing like sailors and stuff but one
in a way I thought I was pretty
realistic you know remembering being
that age and having remembering having
brothers that age in friends that age it
wasn't really that unrealistic and the
fact that you remember how at that age
everything was a huge [ __ ] deal
I mean this kissing party because you
know the main character played by Jacob
Tremblay whose name is Max and he's just
adorable he was the kid in the predator
he was in room and stuff
this is adorable like angelface little
child and his whole thing is he wants to
kiss the girl he's good and he's gonna
marry her and they're gonna be frit
together whatever yeah it's so cute so
it's like it's kind of like yes on the
surface it's like this raunchy comedy
with very very young children and that
might upset some people I don't know but
well they're tweens yeah at its heart it
is a very sweet surprisingly like a
coming-of-age story and like boys this
age you're just on the cusp of
adolescence and they're learning that
you know things that seemed like this
big huge deal or this big huge drama at
the time really aren't that important
the grand scheme of things maybe these
friends that you grew up with it you
thought you'd be friends with forever
maybe that's not gonna happen
you know maybe you'll grow apart when
you get a maybe your parents could be
yeah so like the real world is like
intruding on them and I think they
balanced that really well and like I
said I think that's why it doesn't
descend into just a mean spirit it's is
not a mean spirited movie at all Jerry I
would show this to a kid that that's
what I mean and I was like I don't have
a kid you know I don't have a kid and if
I had but if I had a kid this age
especially a boy I don't think I would
have any compunctions about showing them
um you know your mileage may vary
obviously but I think it's very like
that anyway that's what I mean so I
don't really think it's anything they're
not gonna see anything that's gonna
shock them I don't think I mean I don't
know but you know remembering what it
was like being 12 I like that
nowadays it seems like because um like a
year ago or two years ago where that
maybe eighth grade came out which was
like a very realistic depiction of like
kids that age you know so I think that
it's good that they're kind of getting
rid of this myth of like children as
these little perfect innocence and
everything like that but that said I
think the innocence of these kids is
where the humor comes from it's not
laughing at them it's just finding humor
they don't know they're talking in them
trying to find their way in the world
and not knowing anything yeah but you
know that they'll learn later on and
it's like and it's just kind of cute and
sweet like to see them doing this kind
of stuff and like what they says yeah
there's a happy ending each one of them
it kind of shows you know they have
their triumphs at the end they have
their triumphs yeah you know each one
each one has their own version of a
tribe oh and that musical yeah that
musical laughs no one in the end yeah
it's you know I I just I don't remember
laughing this much in a comedy for quite
a while I mean I just liked it this is a
[ __ ] hilarious hilarious maybe like I
said a lot of its gonna go with it you
know if you liked super bad if you like
that kind of raunchy like r-rated comedy
and you can handle seeing like twelve
year old kids getting involved in it
then this would you know then this would
probably be right up your alley I
thought it was hysterical and it also
like had a real good heart to it and the
care and the three kids at the center of
it are just they were just adorable it
was just and I don't really like kids
and movies generally because they were
usually annoying but these three were
like just so good and their characters
were so well developed that you you know
you were kind of rooting for him because
they were they were just these dorky
kids like they got just caught up in
these Crypt this crazy [ __ ] adventure
with drugs and dildos possible
pedophiles played by Stephen Merchant
that was a nice little cameo I really
but yeah so definitely very very funny
movie so check it out
[Music]